السعوديه والارجنتين في لقاء مرتقب
بالمجموعه الثالثه من كاس العالم لكنها
ليست مواجهه الاولى التي تجمع الفريقين
حيث التقيا في اربع مناسبات من قبل
البدايه في يوليو 1988 في مباراه تنظيم
بطوله الكاس الذهبيه الاسره الوديه وهنتهت
وقتها المباراه بالتعادل الايجابي بنتيجه
اثنين مقابل اثنين
لقاء الثاني لم تنتظر كثيرا حيث اقيمت
مباراه اخرى تجمع الفريقين لتحديد المركز
الثالث في نفس البطوله وحسمها المنتخب
الارجنتيني بهدفين نظيفين ال 20 من اكتوبر
عام 1992 كانت المباراه الرسميه الوحيده
التي جمعت بين الفريقين في نهائي كاس
الملك فهد الذي تحول لاحقا الى بطوله كاس
القارات وكان الفوز من نصيب الارجنتين
بنتيجه ثلاثه مقابل واحد وبعد 20 عاما من
المباراه الثالثه وتحديدا في عام 2012
استضاف استاد الملك فهد الدولي بالرياض
مباراه وديه بين الفريقين وانتهت بالتعادل
السلبي